I'll start my diagram with the last
commit that the coin branch has in
common with the master branch as you can
see that's the revert controls commit
here I'll use an ellipsis to indicate
that there's more history off over here
after this commit our history branches
off into the master branch and the coin
branch so I'll split off here keeping
the master branch straight each of these
two branches has several more commits
I'll label the last commit made on each
branch with the appropriate branch label
now remember we also made a new branch
off of master called ez mode and made
one commit on it so we'll add that to
the diagram as well